ils sont plus d'un million de licenciés
en france et depuis des décennies ils
dictent leur loi
on ne demande rien qu'on nous laisse
chassé par un grill
les chasseurs sont ultra organisés
regroupées en fédération départementale
et à chaque proposition de loi en leur
défaveur il se mobilise mobilisation
face caméra les manifestations exemple
en 1998 où les chasseurs étaient contre
les directives européennes sur les dates
de chasse du gibier d'eau il s'en
prenait alors directement à la ministre
de l'environnement de l'époque je venais
pas les chasseurs pouvait se tromper
entré pour voir si elle est venue j'en
ai plusieurs mois faisait fuir la maison
mais il ya aussi les mobilisations en
dehors des caméras et depuis les années
80 les chasseurs ne se cache pas de
faire du lobbying un moyen d'influencer
directement les députés et sénateurs et
en 1989
ils font de même le parti chasse pêche
nature et tradition pour s'opposer au
bon score des verts leurs ennemis jurés
les élections européennes
nous n'avons rien à cacher nous sommes
en train de nous organiser aujourd'hui
un lobby multiples politiques pour se
faire aider dans ce travail de lobbying
ils font alors appel au maître en la
matière thierry costes il ne cessera de
défendre les intérêts des chasseurs
vers 2002 lors de l'élection
présidentielle il est même le conseiller
politique du candidat cpnt
bonjour on se fait la bise à un moment
c'est toujours une belle femme change
aussi très facile à gérer il est comme
tout tous les gens qui ont du caractère
quand il en a marre il en a marre va
quand même pas reprocher à quelqu'un
d'avoir du caractère
thierry costes lobbystes a subi je
défend des intérêts des gens qui payent
je ne choisis pas nécessairement les
causes connaît par coeur les couloirs de
l'assemblée nationale
il arrive à convaincre les députés de la
droite au ps en passant même par les
communistes
je me retrouve avec pierre paul jacques
pour une bonne cause je suis prêt à
m'allier avec n'importe qui 01/12 juste
à poser bien superposés en 12,1
superposé dont canons superposés selon
partir du cas nous cessons les gens
populaires qui vont à la chasse ce sont
des gens qui font des sacrifices énormes
qui ne prennent pas de vacances
la france est le premier pays de l'union
européenne en nombre de chasseurs une
force électorale
et ça les élus l'ont bien compris
emmanuel macron conseillé par thierry
costes a récemment divisé par deux le
prix du permis de chasse nationale un
geste fou sans nicolas hulot ministre de
l'environnement à la démission
[Musique]